this episode is made possible by the
realistic online game war thunder check
out this game through the link below go
through that link and not only do you
support this show be you get a free
premium tank aircraft or ship and three
days of premium time as a bonus and
let's get into it let's play a game if I
say Cuba and then I mentioned a leader
who ratified a constitution backed by
the people instituted land reforms
legalized the Communist Party cooperated
with the trade unions and actively
opposed fascism who's gonna come to mind
Fidel Castro Che Guevara oh yes
absolutely but one man did it all
nineteen years before they came to power
none other than their spawn rival Cuban
dictator Fulgencio Batista confused well
you should be but keep on watching to
learn more about the complex life of a
man who rose from the very bottom of the
social scale and ended up ruling the 4th
largest economy in Latin America and
also made an alliance with the Mafia
escaped an assassination attempt thanks
to sent yerim magical practices and
eventually fled at dawn with three cargo
planes filled with loot let's get into
it
[Music]
palacio batista es el Divo was born on
the 16th of January 1901 from a family
of impoverished farmers in banyas Cuba
not far from the estate in which Fidel
Castro would come to life in a wealthy
household of landowners this was only
three years after Cuba had gained
freedom from Spain's colonial dominance
following the span of American war in
1898 the US Congress had passed the
teller amendment granting full
independence to Cuba but this was
partially revoked by the Platt Amendment
of 1901 which gave the power to the US
governments to intervene in the island
nation if American interests there were
threatened and Washington had plenty of
motivation to be involved in Cuban
politics 30 to 50 million to be precise
as early as 1896 President Grover
Cleveland stated that America
investments in Cuban sugar cane
plantations railroads mining and other
enterprises amounted to 30 to 50 million
US dollars which is about 1.5 billion
dollars in today's money as a result
Cuban politics economy and society were
often in turmoil badly managed by a
string of corrupt presidents who ruled
to please the land owner elite with
substantial u.s. backing just as an
example consider the story of the P I
see partido indepent a de colo or
colored independent party this was
founded by afro cuban veterans of the
war against Spain in 1908 the party won
enough votes to threaten the rule of
then president gomez to which he reacted
by disbanding it as a pretext he cited a
law which forbade the creation of
parties based on race law which was
meant to protect the ruling white Cuban
elite when the p IC staged to revolt
gomez launched a bloody crackdown backed
by the Regular Army and US troops that
were sent to protect American interests
5,000 afro Cubans died in the struggle
many of them lynched by mobs who had
then stirred to attack any citizen of
color this was the country in which
young Valencia tried to make his way
Batista had a mixed ancestry Spanish
African Chinese and native Caribbean
how could he an impoverished rural half
caste a mulatto how could he possibly
leave his mark in a Cuba dominated by
white landowners one such way was the
army which she joins in 1921 as a
private more out of necessity than as a
vocational choice young Valencia had
ambitions and his service in the army
helped him support his studies as a
stenographer and journalist while
stations in the wha-hey suburb of havana
private Batista met and fell in love
with a girl called Alice agood Dinah's
Gomez she came from a similar rural
backgrounds and to move to the city
after a father got a job at a
psychiatric hospital
Silencio and Eliza they married on the
10th of July 1926 and they would go on
to have three children murder
Valencia ribbon and ELISA later but
apparently Batista was not fully
satisfied by married life and when Songz
you have at least two officially
recognized affairs the first one with
the mother of a girl called Fermina born
out of wedlock whom he
legally recognize the seconds where the
lady called marta fernandez but more on
this a bit later in 1928 private easter
became sergeant Batista and he was
assigned to the barracks of Camp
Colombia in Havana it was here that he
made contact with fellow servicemen who
secretly opposed the rule of President
Gerardo match at all thanks to his
personal charisma he developed a large
network of followers which placed him at
the center of conspirator circles
president Matador admit in power since
1925 and it started with good intentions
putting an end to the plat agreements
and u.s. interference as well as
transforming Cuba into the Switzerland
of the Americas but a recession in 1928
worsened by the Wall Street Crash of
1929 led to political instability and
growing opposition from students trade
unions and the military in July 1933
u.s. envoy's Sumner Welles went full
plats on Matador and made him step aside
helping to install new president Carlos
Manuel fest Bader's the new guy had just
finished unpacking his briefcase when he
was ousted by the revolt of the
sergeants in September and by the way if
they pointed this video you knew scouts
of Cuba president's coming and going do
you not worry so did the Cubans but
let's get back to the sergeants their
leader was none other than Phil Han see
a Batista who had seized the occasion to
rise through the ranks and stick it to
Uncle Sam in one single action and he
must give credit to this man on this
occasion an army sergeant has formal
authority over 10 to 30 soldiers at best
that is why military cooze are carried
out by Colonels or generals with
thousands of troops under their orders
and yet he managed to lead a successful
revolt based only on charisma and
informal leadership but Eastern his
sergeants replaced the president with a
new presidents professor Ramon growl
Batista gave himself a promotion and
became chief of staff of the army with
the rank of colonel
[Music]
in the following years the newly
appointed Colonel Batista would hold
power in the shadows pulling strings to
make or break presidencies and further
his plans he did not mind cooperating
with the u.s. from the start for example
in late 1933 professor grout launched
some attempts at reformed that his time
in office was characterized by social
instability and constant opposition
after only a hundred days Grau received
the deluxe plat treatments by Sumner
Welles with Batista's full support and
cooperation Cuba needed stability and
growl was not the right man
Batista then handed over the presidency
to Colonel Carlos Mende Atta who had the
approval of most factions and most
importantly of the United States in June
1934 President Roosevelt concluded a
treaty with Cuba that finally abrogated
once and for all the Platt Amendment
this was not the end of American
interference in Cuban affairs but at
least it wasn't formally sanctioned
anymore
FDR may have also realized that the
political factions in Cuba had been
exploiting the amendment to their
advantage by creating unrest to trigger
American interventions on their side
more presidents came and went under
Batista Barnett's
six months Arius six months
brooo three years ten months and good on
him for lasting that long now just
before we get into Batista's run for
president let me tell you a bit about
today's sponsor war thunder best way for
me to show you that game is to jump over
to the computer hello everybody welcome
to war thumbs in this game us go to
battle in this game you can point there
are some 1,200 historically accurate
vehicles I'm playing the tanks have
eight tanks in my crate favorites but
you can also play with ships you can
play it with planes they're available
all the way from the
1920s to the 1990s at AZ to the 1990s
I'm starting with my convertible tank
today and look at this I mean this is a
really beautiful game you can rock I am
running into this on purpose just to
show you quite how destructive this
whole environment is like that I can
knock that tower over see how great is
that
oh god okay it seems I'm alright oh my I
am I'm going to hide because one of
those guys is bound to be a good shot
whoa some guys shooting me through that
door that's crazy
he's my ally but how can how can you not
do something like this how can you're
not oh that was hilarious there's lots
of different ways you can play this game
you can play it on just okay if you want
a quick game all the way through to like
much more difficult modes where if
you're a bit of a pro you can still be
challenged sooner guys this is war
thunder check it out to get a free few
days of premium time and a ship a plane
or a tank a premium one by the way
through our link below and let's get
back to today's video
[Music]
president bruise term in office takes us
to October 1940 at time the new
elections tired of being Z power in the
shadows Batista finally decided to run
for the presidency supported by a
coalition which included the Cuban
Communist Party which himself had
legalized in the previous decade his
main opponent in the 1940 election was
an old acquaintance professor growl this
is when colonel valencia batista the
former and future leader of revolts and
coos stepped into power as a
democratically elected representative of
the people one can only imagine the
sense of achievement felt by the son of
farm laborers who became the soldier and
a sergeant a colonel the driving force
behind Cuba's string of rulers and
finally its first non-white presidents
in a country historically ruled by
sugarcane tycoons of European percent
Batista's presidential term from 1940 to
1944 is generally viewed in a positive
light by historians during this period
Batista oversaw the drafting of a new
constitution a progressive documents
which called for government intervention
in the economy and provided a social
safety net his policies included
economic and agrarian reform cooperation
with
trade unions an expansion of the
educational system and an active
opposition to fascism made explicit by
declaring war on Germany and Italy on
the 8th of December 1941 all in all it
was a period of growth stability and
democratic developments for the island
nation but he still ruled well although
he did take the opportunity to enrich
himself after his term ended in 1944
Batista stepped aside preferring to
sponsor new candidate Carlos salad Regas
who was defeated by Professor growl yep
that same guy from before but Easter
soon left the country and lived for a
while in Florida where he increased his
wealth by investing the huge sums that
he had acquired in Cuba the following
year 1945 Batista finally divorced from
Elias Aaron's married his longtime
mistress Marta Fernandez Miranda who
would give him four more children during
his years of absence growls
administration became known for its
corruption and irresponsibility a great
disappointment for the Cuban electorate
who saw growl as a pure hero from the
1933 revolt this malcontents it paved
the way for Batista to return to the
islands this time as the senator in 1948
[Music]
from 1948 to 1952 Cuba was run by
elected president Priya sucker ass like
a growl he was an ambitious and
idealistic leader whose agenda got
marred by corruption and economic
stagnation when new elections were
called to take place in June 1952
Batista ran for office for a second time
anticipating a defeat the colonel
launched a bloodless gulper or a coup on
the 10th of March 1952 Washington
immediately recognized this new Cuban
government's it became clear from the
start that Batista's approach to running
the country had radically changed from
his early presidency first he suspended
the 1940 Constitution that he himself
had instituted and canceled most of the
remaining civil liberties whereas in
1940 he had sought the alliance of trade
unions and the Communist Party he now
backed the wealthier landowners who
owned sugar plantations the gap between
rich and poor it increased and
government corruption was rife whereas
in 1940 his accumulation of wealth
appeared as a byproduct of his populist
rule now
the reaping of profits was his only
evident goal and finally whereas in
previous years in power he had sought
cooperation with the US only as a means
to fulfill his political goals he now
welcomes with open arms the intervention
of both America's government and its
private sector by the late 1950s the US
corporations owned 90% of Cuban mines 80
percent of public utilities 50 percent
of the railways 40 percent of the sugar
production and 25 percent of bank
deposits in an effort to boost tourism
Batista also invited a different kind of
American entrepreneurship to invest in
an industry as Cuban as cigar and rum
production and that's gambling if you
have seen the Godfather Part 2 you will
surely remember a long section set in
Havana in which Michael Corleone meets
gangster Hyman Roth who runs the
profitable gambling business in Cuba in
Koontz with the government this Roth
character is inspired by real-life
gangster
Mayr Lansky a high-ranking mobster of
the Jewish mafia Lansky and legendary
Italo American mafioso Lucky Luciano had
been cooperating with Batista since his
Florida years when the dictator had
seized power in 1952 he had realized
that to attract the right kind of
tourism and investments he needed to
clean up Havana's casinos and red-light
districts and who better could do this
than the mob Lansky in particular had a
real talents to organized complex
operations and have businesses run like
clockwork he took charge of the casinos
becoming a sort of unofficial but
much-needed minister of gambling so what
did Lansky Luciano and other mobsters
such as Santo Trafficante get in return
well for starters they got loads of
money from Batista's governments but
most of all they had free reign and
dealing cocaine in and out of the
islands this was a time when VIP members
at one of the smarter Havana nightclubs
had their own lockers to hold their
cocaine stash this was a time when
Havana was a volatile mix of Monte Carlo
Casablanca in the ancient city of Cadiz
rolled into one a [ __ ] brew of
high-stakes gambling secret
revolutionary plots violent repression
and gangsterism and yes the unholy
alliance of Batista with the mob was
just a minor symptom of the broader
illness plaguing Cuba in the 1950s
government corruption unemployment
exploitation of a low-paid female labor
USA interference and the toxic
dependence on a single crop economy
sugarcane this system was due for a
collapse and the young lawyer he was
going to accelerate its demise and now
enters the picture Fidel as public
dissent increased Batista tightened his
control over the media by way of
censorship and created an anti communist
secret police to intimidate the
opposition by means of violence torture
and executions between 10 and 20,000
people were murdered under the Batista
regime with financial and military
support from Washington historian Arthur
Schlesinger jr. who would become an aide
to John Kennedy analyzed Batista's Cuba
in these terms the corruption of the
governments the brutality of the police
the regime's indifference to the needs
of the people for education medical care
housing for social justice and economic
justice is an open invitation to
revolution this invitation but it was
RSVP to by the July 26th movements led
by lawyer and politician Fidel Castro
now let's take a quick break here
because we have covered extensively the
stages of the revolution in our video
about Fidel Castro and his ally Che
Guevara if you want to know more about
the fight against Batista's regime from
their perspective make sure you check
out our videos on that you will find
links in the description below today we
are going to look at this revolutionary
struggle from the perspective of the
losing side
Batista's and more specifically how did
it happen that Batista lost against the
July 26th movement despite having full
control of the armed forces and facing a
less formidable opposition according to
riders know Berto Fuentes and Carlos
Alberto Montana Batista need three
strategic blunders in the fight against
Castro which would
bring about his defeat on the 26th of
July 1953 Fidel his brother Roland a
hundred and sixty other men attacks the
munkar army barracks in Santiago hoping
to spark a general uprising they didn't
most of the insurgents were killed and
the Castro brothers were arrested but he
still had Fidel in his grip and yet he
let him get away during a general
amnesty in 1955 and this was the first
blunder Fidel fled to Mexico on the 2nd
of December 1956 he returned to Cuba
aboard the yacht Granma followed by 81
revolutionaries hoping to spark an
uprising they didn't and most of the
insurgents were kills
however Castro and a few others made it
to the jungles of the Sierra Maestra
Batista's army instead of pushing the
invaders back to the sea chased them to
the interior of the islands giving them
a shot of a successful guerrilla
campaign and this was the second blunder
as Castro's followers increased in
numbers and their actions became more
effective Batista missed the opportunity
to finish them quickly in Montana's
words Batista does not finish Fidel out
of greed his is a government of Thieves
do you have this small guerrilla band in
the mountains is to his advantage so
that he can order special defense
expenditures that he can steal and yes
that is the third blunder by the time
Batista sent a significant force of
10,000 soldiers Castro had become too
strong and the Regular Army too corrupt
to be effective
but the 26th of July Movement was not
the only fo the regime to contend with
another organization called direct Oreo
revelry scenario revolutionary
directorís at Batista in their sights
just like Castro's disagreements the
Directorate plans a direct attack on the
presidential palace in Havana with the
aim of assassinating Batista on the 13th
of March 1957 a commando of the
Directorate launched an assault on the
palace surrounding the building and
fighting their way through its rooms
with gunfire and hand grenades beyatch
ozan to attack in the late afternoon at
time in which Batista notoriously spent
working in his office on the second
floor but when they found their way into
the office Batista had disappeared the
attack ended in failure and
incarceration for those involved it
later appeared that Batista installed a
secret door in his office well hidden
behind a plastic panel upon hearing the
incoming shots and explosions it simply
slipped through the secret passage and
escaped to safety but why would he need
such a passage personal safety would be
a perfectly normal explanation but we
actually have a better one Natalya
Bolivar is an expert of Santeria that
religious practices of African origin
practiced by some minorities in Cuba
according to her Batista had a
fascination with these type of rites one
of them being the pleasure of the year
in the ceremony priests will determine
which sign or letter will dominate a
certain year at Easter was informed that
the sign for 1957 was a Barham a meaning
the King must find an escape from the
places where he dwells a secret escape
and so Batista was inspired to install
the secret door just one month prior to
the assassination attempt now he had
managed to escape that specific attack
that he was not going to be safe for
long Fidel Raul and che they were
getting closer and closer to Havana
according to writer
TJ English Batista spent the last weeks
of the revolution secluded in his palace
with his sanity almost gone The Dictator
would spend his days gorging on fine
foods interrupting his banquets only to
watch American horror movies and throw
up in his garden on the 27th of December
1958 a train carrying a much-needed load
of weapons and ammunition for the
Regular Army was captured by Che Guevara
in Santa Clara the teaster realized that
his defenses were now doomed he
abdicated his presidency and in the
early hours of the first of January 1959
he fled from Havana to the Dominican
Republic he brought along 40 family
members and loyal supporters as well as
the bare necessities 300 to 700 million
dollars worth of embezzled funds pieces
of art as well as other assets and these
were all stashed in three cargo planes
he applied for asylum in the United
States but Washington had long withdrawn
its support to the losing side of the
Revolution the teaster relocated instead
to Portugal and finally Marbella in
Francoist Spain which in those years
while say common sanctuary for military
dictators fascists and escaped Nazis but
he still lived his last years in
splendor surrounded by the children from
his second marriage who described him as
a man who never raised his voice he
always displayed great affection and
tenderness to us and our mother he was
in general likeable and sympathetic to
everybody history though has judged him
otherwise
Valencia Batista died on the 6th of
August 1973 of a heart attack a team of
assassins sent by Castro due to kill him
on the 8th so we'd like to hear your
judgement of today's protagonist please
do leave your comments below this video
was Batista the first truly effective
revolutionary that Cuba badly needed or
was he simply a social climber motivated
purely by greed all along and I really
hope you enjoyed the video if you did
please do smash that like button also
we've got a new channel sister channels
of this one it's called Geographics if
this one's about people that one is
about places it is linked to below
please do go and subscribe if you think
you might enjoy that and as always thank
you for watching
[Music]